Testing one, two, three, four,
five,
six, seven, eight, nine, ten,
11, 12,
13, 14, 15, 16, 17, 18,
19.
Testing one, two, three, four,
five,
six, seven, eight
>> Good morning.
I'm Paula with the Library of
Congress and I want to welcome
to you a very special story time
at the library.  I love reading,
don't you?  It's so much fun.
We're excited to be teaming up
with the Dolly Parton
Imagination Library to
introduce to you some wonderful
authors who feel share their
stories.  Fun.
She and her team have given away
over 100 million books to help
encourage young readers like
you.
Here at the Library of Congress
we share their passion for
developing young readers and we
know the best way to
encourage people like you to
read is to make reading fun.
So that's what we're here to do.
I hope you enjoy today's story
time.  Even more, I hope you
keep reading at home and having
fun.
Today we will warm up by singing
some
songs, touching your toes, and
then get comfortable, and get
ready to see a story.  Now,
let's get started.
>> Welcome, welcome, everyone,
to the Library of Congress.
Glad to have you joining us
today.  My name is Ms. Caroline
for the Young Readers' Center
and today we have some very
special readers.  Mr. Steve from
American folk life.  All right.
So today we are featuring the
songs
and stories of the great UK,
British
author and song composure, Julia
Donaldson.  So she is absolutely
prolific and the whole story
time will be her material.
She is a former children's
lawyer rat Leuareate of the
United Kingdom.  We're going to
start with our usual hello
songs.  Remember, we're going to
do hello friends.
Salute, hello friends, you link
your index finger, then hello
three times and then it's time
to say hello.  Hello friends.
Hello friends.  Hello friends.
It's time to say hello.  Great.
All right.
So let's do open shut them to
wake up our brains.
Open shut and open shut and give
a little clap clap clap.
Open shut and open shut and put
them in your.
(SPEAKERS OVERLAPPING)lap lap
lap.
Creep and crawl and creep and
crawl up to the very tip tip
tip.
Open up your little mouth.  Wide
eyes.
Open chest and open chest and
give
little clap clap clap.
Open chest and open chest and
put them
in your lap lap lap.
Creep and crawl and creep and
crawl
and right up to your chin, which
I know, which I know.
Open up your little mouth good
job.
All right.  Well, Mr. wizard,
will you read us a poem?
>> I will.
I'm going to read a poem by
Julia  Donaldson.  This foam is
about reading.  That's why it's
so great.  It's called I opened
a book.
I opened a book and in I strode.
Now nobody can find me.
I've left my chair, my house, my
road, my town, and my world
behind me.
I'm wearing the cloak, slipped
on the  ring.
I've swallowed the magic
position.
I dived in a bottomless ocean.
I opened a book and made some
friends.
I shared their tears and lafo
lafort
laster and followed the road to
its happily ever after.  I
finished my book and out I came.
The cloak no longer can hide me.
My chair and my house are just
the
same, but I have a book inside
me.
>> Thank you.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> All right. Well, we have a
very special book
today about a spooky monster
named the gruffalo.  Mr. Steve,
will you have a seat?
>> I will. I will.
>> Well, this book is also by
Julia
Donaldson, and it's called "The
Gruffalo"."  A mouse took a
stroll through the deep, dark
wood.  A fox saw the mouse, and
the mouse looked good.
Where are you going to, little
brown mouse?
Come and have lunch in my
underground house.  It's
terribly kind of you, fox, but,
no, I'm going to have lunch with
a gruffalo.  A gruffalo?  What's
a gruffalo?  A gruffalo.  Why,
didn't you know?
He has terrible tusks and
terrible claws and terrible
teeth in his terrible jaws.
Where are you meeting him?  Here
by these rocks and his favorite
food is roasted fox.  Roasted
fox?
I'm off, fox said.  Good-bye,
little mouse, and away he sped.
Cheerio, fox.
Doesn't he know there's no such
thing as a gruffalo?  On went
the mouse through the deep, dark
wood.  An owl saw the mouse and
the mouse looked good.
Where are you going to, little
brown mouse?
Come and have tea in my tree top
house.
It's quite nice of you owl, but,
no,
I'm going to have tea with a
gruffalo.  A gruffalo?  What's a
gruffalo?
A gruffalo, why didn't you know?
He has knobbly knees and turned
up toes and a poisonous wart on
the end of his nose.  Where are
you meeting him?  Here by this
stream and his favorite
food is owl ice cream.
Owl ice cream?
Whohee, good-bye little mouse,
and away owl flew.
Silly old owl, doesn't he know
there's no such thing as a
gruffalo.  On went the mouse
through the deep,
dark wood.  A snake saw the
mouse and the mouse looked good.
Where are you going to, little
brown mouse?
sss.
Come for a feast in my log pile
house.  Sssss.  It's wonderfully
great of you but no I'm having a
feast with a gruffalo.  A
gruffalo?  What's a gruffalo?
Why, didn't you know?  His eyes
are orange, his tongue is black.
He has purple pimples all over
his back.  Where are you meeting
him?  Here by this beach and his
favorite
food is scrambled snake.
Scrambled snake?  It's time I
hid.  Good-bye, little mouse.
SSS.
And away snake slid.
Silly old snake, doesn't he know
there's no such thing as a G.
ruffal -- oh, but who is this
creature with terrible clause
and terrible teeth and terrible
jaws?  He has knobbly niece and
turned-out toes and a poisonous
wart on the end of his nose.
His eyes are orange.  His tongue
is black.
He has purpose pimples all over
his back.
Oh, no, it's a gruffalo.
>> We're going to sing the
gruffalo song now.  All right.
>> Top find out whraps what
happens.
>> Ms. Julia will be singing.
♫♫
>> he had terrible tusks and
terrible claws and terrible feet
and terrible jaws.  He's a
gruffalo.   Gruffalo.  Gruffalo.
He's a gruffalo.
>> He's got claws.
♫♫
He has knobbly knows and turned
out tow and his a poisonous wart
on the end of his nose.  He's a
gruffalo.
He's a gruffalo, gruffalo,
gruffalo.  He's a gruffalo.
His eyes are orange, his tongue
is black.
He has purple pimples all over
his back.  He's a gruffalo,
gruffalo, gruffalo.
He's a gruffalo.  Gruffalo.
He's a
Grrrrrr Uffalo.  He's a
gruffalo.
>> The gruffalo.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> So now we wonder what's going
on.  As you may remember, the
mouse has just encountered the
real gruffalo in the woods.
.
My favorite food, the gruffalo
said.  You'll taste good on a
slice of bread.
Good, said the mouse.  Don't
call me good.  I'm a mysterious
creature in this wood.  Just
walk behind me and soon you'll
see everyone is afraid of me.
All right said the gruffalo,
bursting with raver. laughter.
You go ahead and I'll follow
after.  They walked and walked
until the
gruffalo said I hear a hiss
ahead.  It's snake said the
mouse.  Why hello.  Snake took
one look at the gruffalo.   Oh,
crumbs, he said.  Good-bye
little mouse.
And off he slid to his log pile
house.  You see said the mouse?
I told you so.  Amazing said the
gruffalo.
They walked some more until the
gruffalo said I hear a hoot in
the trees ahead.  It's owl, said
the mouse.  Why, owl, hello.
Owl took one look at the
gruffalo.  Oh, dear, he said,
good-bye little mouse, and off
he flew to his tree top house.
You see, said the mouse?  I told
you so.
Astounding, said the gruffalo.
They walked some more until the
gruffalo said I can hear feet on
the path ahead.  It's fox said
the mouse.  Why, fox, hello.
Fox took one look at the
gruffalo.
Oh, good-bye he said and off he
ran to his underground house.
Well, said mouse everyone is
afraid of me but now my tummy is
beginning to rumble and my
favorite food is gruffalo
crumble.  Gruffalo crumble, the
gruffalo said,
and quick as the wind he turned
and fled.
All was quiet in the deep, dark
wood.
The mouse found a nut and the
nut was good.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> All right. Fantastic. Here
we go.  Whoops.
We're going to sing a song now
based
on one of Julia's little list of
flat books, which is called it's
a little baby.  So we're going
to do some -- it's an action
song.
So we're going to peak through
our fingers first, then we're
going to point.  Then we're
going to wave.
And then clap and finally dance.
So let's have everybody do those
action when is we sing them
them.
.
♫♫
Somebody's hiding.  I wonder
who.  It's a little baby and
she's peaking at you.
Can you peak, can you peak, can
you peak too?  Somebody's
hiding.  I wonder who.
It's a little baby and he's
pointing at you.  Can you point?
Can you point?  Can you point
too?  Somebody's hiding.  I
wonder who.
It's a little baby and he's
waiving at you.  Can you wait?
Can you wait?  Can you wait too?
Somebody's hiding.  I wonder
who.
It's a little baby and he's
clapping with you.
Clap, clap, can you clap too?
Somebody's hiding.  I wonder
who.
It's a little baby and she's
dancing
for you.  Can you dance?  Can
you dance too?  Wonderful.
Thank you.
.
We've come to the end of our
live stream.  So let's do our
good-bye song, which is the
opposite of the hello.
We're going to wave and then --
wave friends three times.
Say good-bye.  All right.
♫♫
Good buy friends.  Good-bye
friends.
Good-bye friends.
It's time to say good-bye.
♫♫
>> Come again.
Stw